oh yeah also when you were growing up
right did you ever because I don't know
if you'd go to did you ever go to
swimming pools a lot like America or did
you do this a lot in the summer time
dude I don't know like did you ever have
to they tell you men be careful about
like verucas oh you heard of these
things yeah yeah I wonder if it's got an
American name because that sounds so
British I feel like that's painfully
what is it called wait what Veruca
Veruca it's like an ingrown wart kind of
thing yeah American war for Veruca uh
plantart what plantar wart I've never
heard of that
um I've never heard of that uh it's like
you would um you'd have to be careful I
guess maybe it's a kid like only for
kids uh it's not only for kids yeah it's
like you have to be careful going in the
pool if you had one and they would be
like kids if you have one don't come in
the pool uh and it was basically like
you could get it by just walking on the
same ground as somebody else who has it
like Barefoot so it's like a wart you
get on your foot or yeah
it kind of like a wart that grows into
the skin
um okay yes yes I I don't think we use
the same word for yes yeah yeah okay
we don't have the same word for it yeah
it's like a hole yeah it is actually
kind of like because I had a Veruca for
years and I did not know how to remove
it
um so there's a lot of like different
methods oh I know what you're gonna say
well I feel like okay I thought you were
gonna because you can freeze it off you
know no yeah you can freeze it off which
is what I tried doing
um no no like there is there is
literally a device you can buy in
England which yeah which is kind of like
a freeze dry and you freeze the warts
for all like a certain amount of time a
day yeah you like uh scrape it off yeah
yeah and then you like continue yeah
yeah yeah you continue doing that
um
parmesan
yeah so I tried doing that for like what
felt like months and I just did not go
away I don't know why it didn't work
maybe I was doing it wrong
um and then I realized it might be
herpes
so then I just got [__] tired of like
putting either like
I tried freezing it and then I went to a
doctor and then he gave me like acid
that you can put on it which you put on
it like you apply a little bit every day
a layer gets like a leg is uh [__] yeah
it's like Breaking Bad a layer gets
peeled off every day
um that didn't work uh so in the end I
just cut the foot off I just I just was
just it was like a episode from like
alien or something I just [__] gotta
got a [__] knife and just like get
out of here you carved it out I [__]
carved it out oh my god um never got a
Veruca since it works [__] yeah do not
do this dude this is not this is not
medical advice yeah obviously but it
totally [__] worked for me it's quite
a weird how we don't talk about them
anymore and then they never get brought
up and this is the first one I've ever
heard about like yeah why is this like
the thing that I was told a lot about it
and then we just don't talk about it and
then you know the worst thing Sydney uh
Cindy had a Veruca problem as well like
a few years ago tried the same things I
did didn't work as well it would always
like what happened is when you walked
into the kitchen
I just said this worked like let's not
do that because let's do what the doctor
said yeah tried the acid thing tried the
freeze-dry thing what would happen is
that it would get to a point where the
Veruca is really small but you would
never be able to get rid of that it
would always no matter what for some
reason grow back right and become bigger
again so one day she just after months
of trying to trying to deal with it she
she did the [__] knife scissor method
and just stabbed it out and uh yeah it's
it's it's it's gone now
um yeah
just something about the feeling of like
feeding that little [__] that's been
stuck stuck in your life you know the
movies just sort of gets shot and
they're getting the bullet out with the
knife yeah
[Music]
yeah it's painful but yeah satisfying to
get a doubt yeah I wonder how that's not
a problem in onsens or anything because
everyone bathes before they go in but I
don't think that's how I don't think
that matters no I think it's like a
viral thing actually oh yeah how it is
yeah now I'm never gonna step in a
public pool ever again
[__] public pools anyways huh you
don't go in public pools
unless so you go to the public pool
that's true it's probably because also
all the kids are just pissing in the
pool right now
I mean that probably doesn't help let's
be real wait
I've always wondered you know you know
when they say you get stung by a
jellyfish you piss on that yeah is that
like an urban myth no I've done it
I'm pretty sure they they tested this on
like some show maybe Mythbusters they
test this and it was like negligible
yeah it was like really I think it
doesn't do it I'm just trying to find
anything
I think what you're supposed to do is
like put vinegar or some kind of like
base on it to like level out the like
because it's it's basically like acidic
essentially it's like yeah if you
accidentally poured acid on yourself
yeah so what you you should do is like
you pour some kind of Base which is like
maybe vinegar or like some other base
but like who's going to the beach with a
[__] bottle of vinegar it's [__] up
Australians Australians clearly so it's
just like at this point it's just like
please just put anything on it to stop
the burning and it's like I don't have
any water
I've had to piss off my friend's leg
[Laughter]
so was there a jellyfish involved I want
to know before yes
unfortunately
yeah well I gotta call have you ever has
any of you ever been stung by a
jellyfish before never I've never even
been what does it feel like yeah I've
been stung by a bee no I'm so jealous oh
I haven't been sung by B I've been stung
I've been stung by a jellyfish many
times it's [__] horrible what does it
feel like so I've been stung by a you
know the blue bottle jellyfish you see
quite often they're [__] everywhere
in Australia
um yeah it is a good coffee
um but yeah I had one where it was like
wrapped around my arm like that like the
whole way like when I was a kid yeah um
and it literally just feels like someone
is taking like a metal rod like a hot
metal rod and it's just doing this
you know they are they are yeah well
only some jellyfish yeah they they just
like split and they make new versions
they're cute they're just doing their
thing not when it's wrapped around your
[__] I don't think jellyfish are cute
yeah I think jellyfish are cute they're
cute [__] no man like my thalassophobia
gets 10 times worse when you see a group
of jellyfish holy [__] man no get the
jellyfish out of here you're gonna be
stuck deep in the ocean or in a cave
cave the Cave's not underwater is it it
could be a wonderful oh that's just like
two nightmares yeah
or stuck in the ocean but I can't
breathe in the ocean let's say there's
some way we can we can you can breathe
in the depths of the ocean
okay okay would you rather be stuck in
the middle of the ocean on like a float
or something yeah
um for like 24 hours or would you rather
be stuck in a cave for 24 hours oh cave
100 cave yeah 100 quite easy though
because of the float one you can kind of
just chill out just jump chill I would
not be chilling bro yeah I would be
freaking the [__] out yeah they're both
pretty easy
oh that's just survival at this point
right yeah at least in the cave I can
like pick a corner and just sleep but
like what where am I gonna sleep in the
ocean you sleep on the barge it won't be
comfy oh on a cave wood coffee I don't
think we're concerned about the
comfiness of a cake wait which one would
you pick uh uh depends I mean because
like there's there's a lot of variables
like okay he's just scary man it's not a
scary shows the ocean ocean 24 hours is
Chill on a barge that's fine that's
Connor's next video by the way I spent
24 hours on a bar
[__] down you should [__] chill out
you don't know what you do not know
what's down there with a cake with the
boats they don't touch the box with a
cave you can see it coming yeah you
could be trapped in you know you could
be it's dark it's gross that you can't
see anything
um you can't see anything underwater
like you you don't know what's floating
on the top right just like floating on
the top yeah that's fine but because
fish don't they don't give a [__] about
trying to hit officially the least of my
concerns
because it doesn't it doesn't taste like
anything there's no meaning for them to
try and attack you you'll be fine on
like a little boat no I'm sure you'll be
fine tonight either it's just a matter
of like which one am I more mentally
mentally yeah mentally comfortable no
hell no I like the ocean but hell no
like the more I've grown older the more
I realize I definitely have like
thalassophobia really like yeah just did
you have it as a kid or I've always
hated the sea I guess
you know what my dad used to do to teach
me how to swim oh God it's very easy
okay okay I was like seven or something
right six we'd go to the beach he'd pick
me up and just like throw me into the
like deep end of the ocean it's like all
right swim honey
that's what Lions do today oh it's like
well you didn't even like try and teach
you technique he's just no throws you my
dad's not a very good teacher you know
how he's clearly
the way he tried teaching me how to read
the time was he'd point at the clock and
go what time is it and if I couldn't
answer he'd get really mad that is like
the most Asian thing I've ever heard in
my life like the worst
you should have seen him when he was
trying to teach me how to drive oh God
how was that
um he ended up not being the one to
teach me how to drive that's for sure
Jesus yeah unfortunately unfortunately I
hate to call my dad out but he's also
like not the best teacher either because
I remember having a similar experience
uh when my dad tried to teach me how to
ride a bike where where he was kind of
like the teaching method was son you do
this and I yeah yeah you know you do
this it's simple and I was like Dad
what's the technique he's like just do
it just do it she don't know it's like
and obviously I fall off and he's like
doing it wrong it's like what am I doing
wrong just just keep doing it just keep
doing it right it's kind of like a trial
by fire kind of like teaching method
yeah just just do the thing but harder
and better this is the get good man yeah
it literally that's just the Asian
method there is like no Fidelity to
teach you to make techniques the the
technique is just get good and you keep
trying until you get good yeah pretty
much yeah the way they teach math is
what's four times four
Ron do it again yeah how about how what
is it
[Music]
no I didn't drown how
because she got good
so like you would just drown
I think I would just like flail around
and he'd just pick me up and then do it
again
[Music]
I I don't like the ocean it's like one
is from drowning it's like all right
dunking you yeah so I like pools I like
swimming I just don't like doing it in
the sea in the ocean you don't like it
when you can't see the bottom right oh
I've yeah yeah
as soon as we get to that point I'm like
get me the [__] out of here yeah or like
the idea of like rip currents yeah oh
that's what you just get pulled in
there's nothing stopping yeah that's so
[__] terrifying scary man I love the
ocean have you ever been swimming and
then you felt something like a fish or
like seaweed it pretty didn't feel
something
most likely though it was seaweed yeah
oh yeah okay okay yeah I felt that and I
I just you know every time I just feel
like I'm just a little like flicker or
something I [__] I'm like my pants I
literally like shits himself I'm like
get me the [__] out yeah yeah I don't
know it's just something about the ocean
terrifies me about boats you like being
on boats I
have boats
huh I like boats I like boats too yeah
because you're safe yeah I love a boat I
don't know
love a good boat it's a British in me I
think I love about it
it's a sailor in me I love the boats are
chill uh I don't know I like the ocean
but again yeah I think it's terrifying
how little we know about it yada yada
ever gets it yeah it's good of things
down there yeah that's about it now
caves ocean caves the scariest no cave
diving I'm never that's that [__] is the
worst yeah I watch those YouTube videos
about it I'm like all right that's
that's one thing I'm never gonna do you
know I watch those kind of YouTube
videos just to get I don't know why it's
like a morbid curiosity you know yeah
yeah I think the thing that makes it so
terrifying is that if you dive in the
ocean and you're you know you're
exploring these caves like if something
goes wrong you can't come back up yeah
then they can't retrieve you yeah yeah
because you have to decompress for like
like an hour yeah if you go down it's 50
meters it's something like you have to
wait like an hour yeah and then come
back up it's like like what if you run
out of air yeah
it's terrifying it's like caving is
already scary why are you adding the
element of like like hard mode yeah and
cold and you can't see anything yeah